pacientes en camillas a las puertas de
los hospitales es la imagen de los
últimos días en hong kong debido a la
peor ola de kobe 19 que ha sufrido el
territorio semiautónomo desde el inicio
de la pandemia
la variante o micro night sus tragos en
el abarrotado sistema hospitalario y la
escasez de instalaciones de cuarentena
la líder del ejecutivo hongkonés anunció
medidas de contingencia y la
postergación de los comicios para
designar un nuevo líder adiós mansión de
western food en el centro con el pleno
apoyo y la ayuda adicional del gobierno
central vamos a emprender medidas más
duras una de las medidas que estamos
planificando con mucha seriedad es una
prueba universal obligatoria haremos
pruebas a todos los habitantes de hong
kong mente universal test sobre el test
y fraguan en hong kong desde beijing se
han comprometido a proporcionar más
pruebas pcr y equipos médicos
estoy muy decepcionado con la actual
política anti pandemia que ha aplicado
el gobierno de hong kong porque nunca
estuvo en consonancia con las políticas
de control de covite la china
continental
y además las autoridades ampliaron el
plan de vacunación hasta menores de 3
años para recibir la dosis de sinovac
este viernes muchos padres se
apresuraron a inocular a sus hijos
me he dado cuenta de que la pandemia es
cada vez peor y he visto que un niño ha
fallecido por coronavirus a todos nos
preocupa que a ella le ocurra algo
parecido antes engañado de los efectos
secundarios pero ahora ya no me preocupa
tanto
los esfuerzos para alinearse con la
política de 'tolerancia cero' contra el
virus impuesta por china hong kong
también impuso la obligatoriedad del
pasaporte de vacunación a partir del 24
de febrero para acceder a centros
comerciales supermercados peluquerías o
reuniones sociales de más de dos
personas